alright so I started a 15 minute game
playing a pretty high rated opponent yep
slawek PSS 21 something righted this
Russia is very small ikea Russia okay so
we have a bank oh and it's a decline
with 93 and he took on c4 which is
usually considered to be M quite dumb
quite nice for wide just castle and
after black castles I can even play the
instant v5p opening up the position and
there are already some technical issues
in this position for example if he takes
on e 595 and that ft 7 white can already
take on f7 look takes d6 this is some
very good for white
at least that some how I remember it so
it's not necessarily correct but this is
what what I think is a point here okay
can we can just a retreat it the night
it's not it's not a very attractive
looking move but you can play it one
issue is after night d76 must play
Knight b6 cannot take now e 6f vde night
be 655 wins material on a eight at least
in exchange so after 97 e6 he needs to
play Knight b6 immediately and then I
can take on a seven if I want rook takes
and then retreat the bishop probably to
attending Knight to g5 and this exposes
a serious weakness only six so I'm not
sure I can we can try 98 also intending
to recapture on d6 with the night but of
course I'm not I'm not obliged to take
on d6 and in fact them okay he's playing
this okay so I think that taking on b6
is some yeah it's not it's not
necessarily bad
but it doesn't really help me much mmhmm
yeah I guess he's 66 must be there must
be the point otherwise it doesn't make
much sense okay he probably thought
about this beforehand so might be six
now instantly played okay so i can take
on f7 rook takes but should be two and
then 95 the idea i go to e2 not to d3
because of the Bishop g4 pin um that I
need to attend I don't think that going
to eat or d3 now would help much right
it's not bad it's not necessarily bad
okay but checking I'm ahead on the clock
by around one minute and I'd like to
preserve this edge on the clock at least
not for behind too much so now my idea
is 95 a mini idea just attacking the
rook but it aims at the weekend square
only six so let's say let's say you play
some that's not so easy to say what
movie should play actually yeah for
example 97 is just mad refi v6 coming we
cannot move to be 89 we should be seven
is also just giving away e6 now I'm not
quite sure what he's supposed to play
black can think about the move h6
preventing 95 but this weakens g6 at the
whole King side was considerably his
King is already a bit exposed with the F
poor missing and g6 played it's not like
i'm having a king side attack right away
but my his King has deafened
less secure than mine I have the ideal
on formation F to G to h2 gap not sure
maybe night a 62 c7 could be an idea
sometimes this maneuver is good covering
the e6 square and I'm also putting some
pressure on d5 the d5 pawn is yet both
the strength and the weakness it's true
it's a strong point because it supports
this idea of putting a piece on e6 of
course but it is also yeah in a way
isolated it's not supported by an
additional pawn on e4 c4 so it can get a
weakness if Black gets not a 67 we
should be seven and so on the Navy will
probably win the pond but then now this
is not really um yeah so relevant here
because of my 95 ideas I didn't don't
expect that move at all I thought he
needed to ever had three thought he
needed to play me play even-aged sticks
I don't know not that it's looking great
but i thought he and I g5 and Bishop g4
basically a leads to an enormous
position but maybe I'm wrong
this should reform exchanging the
bishops and then I get to e6 and full
effect yeah okay let's not waste any
time I'm going to play this move anyway
um I know Bishop g4 m OS them is there
something I'm different yeah the
question is maybe Bishop d3 this may be
even better
yeah are the same
a Bishop g4 has got the additional idea
of playing 96 immediately Bishop takes
Bishop takes c6 check on the bishop is
not exactly bad on e6 is also on an IDM
well come on it's hard to its kind of
things are hard to determine in such a
limited time it ok it's 15 minute it's
not blitz so I have a bit more time than
then in the usual blitz game but you
need to trust your instincts this looks
a bit more natural to me I have on this
additional 96 idea and turn in most
cases I'm going to take on f5 anyway and
play 96 and by the way in an interesting
additional idea that I thought really
considered properly would have been
bishop f3 intending 96 and after taking
taking with the porn and having this
Bishop on a three but this can easily be
a case where this doesn't really help
much ok so just take and 96 right taking
the the Queen and then I could I could
even just tape g7 next
maybe this is a simple end and good
solution that's not waste too much time
we need this temp why my idea was he
would probably play 27 now it's
interesting and should i take or or do i
have some some better move some
intermediate moves like okay g4 looks
like looks insane it needs to be some
for singles yeah one point is i think i
need to take it come on if he gets night
c7 i need to take any way and I rather
take g7 than a night on tonight
somewhere okay now my idea my original
idea was b3 here to get this Bishop on
the long diagonal now that the g7 Bishop
is gone and dumb yeah now I need to move
the key it's clear that maybe the pawn
on d5 gets lost but the special bond be
to you should be should be an excellent
compensation for that um okay
but how to how to play it exactly clean
22 to h6 mmm maybe
hmm
mmm yeah he will get the pawn it's not
so it's not so clear one issue is some
weekend after getting the dfac one you
can probably play you five at some point
and just block this long diagonal
mmhmm yeah how to how to play this it's
not it's not they're not clear at all
not sure that coming to h6 is really
helping me also thinking about Queen 2g
4g forum settings setting up some some
sort of pin it's not where it's not too
great
hmm maybe this wasn't so great to the
specialty for stuff
yeah it's not like I don't have any
compensation episode have some comp but
it's not it's not not grade or something
ok let's 78 to the age 6 square I don't
see anything anything spectacular yeah I
think you you grab the porno but ok he
could also think about let's say we gave
aid yeah because I'm on Queen h6 he can
play rogue age five if he likes ok
but let's consider
yeah it's also taking f2 of course so
let's say look everyone he can probably
just take f2 and don't don't want that
okay this is like like the most
natural-looking moves under the
circumstances
the question is if he takes on d5 let's
say with the c7 night I could take
immediately opening up the long diagonal
but I could also move the night I mean
let's say two eform intending on a
further journey to g3 rg5 I is playing a
couple of more prophylactic moves yeah
yeah there's some some point to it of
course
hmm yeah how to i would you continue
he's covering the g7 square which would
be the the the meeting square in theory
yeah night maybe 94 94 to g5 look d5
Quincy 35 and then F for something like
that
hmm quite yeah it looked it seems quite
it seems quite um quite easy for white
what else is there a move like rookie 3
of course look III yo rookie form yeah
looking forward to where
look II 4G form e form or III g3 yeah
this is actually an idea it's not not
ridiculous
but i can tell you he takes with the
night 10pm require it's not it's
probably not enough will be 3 95 95 95
group g3 can even play night air for and
that's just nothing going on
okay let's try it this way using this
night not for defense but for a tech
night g3 or 95 or a combination of Queen
age 695 Queen h-60 has this rook age 5
moves on this is why rook f7 was
interesting the downside of rook
upsetness that ninety five wins the
temple yeah let's say look let's say the
night takes and then night g5 would win
a temple and yeah this is this is even
though pretty okay i think but i guess
it will take what the b6 night the c7
night covers e6 and can maybe reboot yae
eight so he will take with the b6 night
if he intends if he takes with the night
at all then I g5 look to have eight then
what hmm
yeah it's not really not really helping
much maybe maybe there's something else
nightby 6595 row cafe diem where's my
great continuation I guess there isn't
one
maybe 93 instead nah particularly we
play real good for
the knight on d5 always prevents this
Queen see three ideas
oh why do I me if he takes my g5 look at
a droopy form and then they look each
for ma maybe if you place each six I
might have ideas like 96 night takes
nidoqueen HD this may be a possibility
so night g5 rogue f ed o'keefe form this
could be could be an idea the telescope
why is gotten i def form yeah he played
it ok night g5 look f a droopy form of
my DM yeah it doesn't really it doesn't
really convey the impression that it
should work I mean really work ok but
anyway what what should I do
so row cafe diem is the the normal move
and yeah what to do we are looking for
was my my latest my latest idea night f4
I'm like a force a possible reply
hmm
h6 mitf 96 this could be it could be
interesting
the immediate capture there is probably
insane iam yeah it is insane okay let me
go let's go here not down invest more
time night f4 I thought I thought maybe
I can try on I can try look everyone
rook takes g5 I have Luke checks a form
okay this is not spectacular but i can i
can continue if you place some some
nothing move i have work edge for this
is but ok it's hard to play nothing in
this position admittedly you you
basically need to make a move that is
some are relevant to this position we
won't play a a six or something okay so
um now look h4 it's not doing much but
ok nitey forum okay let's let's do that
and i have 94 as a possible as a
possible idea sit say h 594
if he plays Knight f6 I might consider a
form yeah f form
on Islam is there something something
something good him
ok
we are getting to the point where you
need to speed up the bad thing is I'm
not threatening anything you know six
f1
I don't really see more good one
I think the threatens g-form g-form
okay okay can play rookie five but I
have Quincy 3 this is at least messy
rocket III I can take and so okay there
are some tricks at this position at
least k may be here
taking milk okay he's sucking it i have
also i have this move activating he
catches I get the Queen it's not clear
where where'd you go now that's black
Hannah maybe he he lost his way but but
ok it so it's very very complicated so
what now take it or look look aged 6 mmm
I hope age 16 maybe you can play em just
a queen g5 yeah I can i name or can they
can take with the pawn
hmm
let's grab it and play gt5 the technique
form
yeah very complicated stuff yeah and we
are down to a little time you were
threatening Queen f7 tending Queen f1
mate this is why I want to get get this
look off Wow
yeah great
yep I didn't see anything else
check check now I have two passes G and
on the far side I'm not sure maybe it's
it's just just a concrete loss it's
possible but i have the jeep on cheap on
a tape on time morning check check it's
just buy one you just buy one checkmate
yeah Dwight unlucky I mean okay not the
old game I mean he played this nicely I
guess but it's a bit unlucky that maybe
maybe there is a win for white I don't
know no I black is winning okay I cannot
be so sure I mean it just just saved by
one tempo and I think he needs to play
exactly like that I don't think he's got
something else I mean if he plays the
king or something I mean he played this
really um I don't know it's a very new
account I know as I saw this wrong sorry
he's got 400 something 15-minute games
yeah okay the problem i think around
here it was certainly okay i mean yeah i
get i get the exchange and it's very
it's very messy okay of course but i
didn't think i should be in bad shape
okay but the count gives black it pretty
clear hmm ok it's just a technical thing
a very concrete concrete thing here I
thought f5 would would help me but
okay yeah odds are very good moves route
default here look the two was better but
ok it'sit's humans not count so around
here but this is yeah this is very good
yeah this is very good I mean age for
overlooked 25 of course but this is just
very strong will get five very strong
move
no I I basically only have saw group
takes that from and this this son really
changes the whole thing yeah if you
would take just for instance then this
is okay I mean what is blacks a big deal
here cannot miss the night because he
for Hanks and his King is also bit
insecure so we cannot easily improve the
position I mean back is ok no no doubt
about that but he's not winning or
something the comp actually gives us is
completely equal probably seeing some
kind of Perpetual but okay Brooke and
fire was was very strong and okay h four
losses losses right away comp wants to
defend with this year again ok this is
at least a bit funky looking good but
the okay black should witnesses this is
too much now now can but I would be
interested to learn if the whole
approach was probably wrong I mean here
I had to add the feeling that them that
I'm excellent here but it didn't really
materialize it should be something that
you get to e6 interesting
computer once the pledgee form yeah yeah
you can't you can think about stuff like
that it's its simular to unto the game
here like this let's say here let's say
something like this this is similar to
the game the difference is less G for
Andrew care 6 inserted and now my d5
porn it's not it's not a weakness yeah
this is interesting this is interesting
of course chief is a weakness of need
but then an interesting way to play an
additional idea is a for attending a 5
ok I this is very sophisticated stuff
hard to figure out in 15 minute ok man
here here of course there's also a
question and yeah in fact I'm thinking
about this you know Bishop g4 or Bishop
d3 is all very nice but let's say I play
some this is not a comp suggestion but
now that I look at it um maybe I should
just play a developing let's say let's
say Bishop e3 or something and say ok
age 6 weakens your position and what are
you playing next after Bishop bg4 for
example he had this night a 6 idea which
is not possible now he cannot really
move this here because of G for dropping
the bishop and yeah yeah probably white
should have something I mean this cannot
be really good weakening yourself like
that but it was obviously a difficult
thing to explore then he defined
this very nicely the store looks looks
good for white I maintained this this
opinion but then it's very complicated
and maybe here the the position is
already okay I mean the thing is I lose
lots of time and really hope for for the
fact that this long diagonal gives me
something but in essence um I probably
give away the pawn yeah yeah this is all
interesting you played this nicely i
guess first defending and then
increasing in the pressure on the five s
is there anyway and it's difficult for
me to to improve my position and this
probably helps him but I didn't want to
play a play any passiveness yeah this is
just fishing I mean and not not with
much prospects yeah an interesting game
thanks for watching